[Music]
all
right hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 208 which is
a special edition not on our usual day I
am Dr Brett Weinstein you are Dr Heather
hying and this is Tesla our darkest cat
this this is this is the darkest cat we
got yeah he just he just sucks in the
photons yep he does and the eggs yes and
the both never met a cat as much of a
fan of scrambled eggs is this one he
loves he loves the scrambled eggs loves
the scrambled eggs all right today we're
going to talk about uh fridy things I
don't even know how to summarize it so
maybe I should not try to I think
actually given the temperature we should
winterize it winterize it man it is cold
here I have no oh boy ads have
unfortunately our pipes yes ads have our
pipes but you know we
persevere live streaming doesn't require
water I mean it requires some water but
yeah you know we we figure out the uh
the fragility in our system and we uh we
get better over time we get anti fragile
yeah hopefully hopefully okay so um
we're here on Saturday um talking to you
we won't be doing a Q&A today and we
won't be back until not next Wednesday
but the following Wednesday uh so this
is this is standing in for our normal uh
Wednesday live stream um but we
encourage you to join us at the watch
party that's happening right now at
locals and uh there's lots of great
stuff that happen at locals when we do
do uh q&as after these they'll be on
locals only we did one this last
Wednesday it was it was great uh very
successful uh we do some amas um mostly
with Brett um Zach and I did an AMA at
locals we release Our Guest episodes
early at locals and um and our Discord
server is available at locals and I did
want to say one thing um about that we
want to mention that the Darkhorse
Discord Community which has been going
strong um basically since we uh made it
available in um as Co started and as we
started doing these live streams in the
spring of 2020 um that our Discord
Community is grieving a loss this week
Brian Williams whom we did not know um
has been active in that Discord
Community since Unity 2020 actually um
and he died this week far too soon um
and I've been told there's been an open
voice chat um going on for more than 24
hours celebrating him and commemorating
him and that Sunday's karaoke which um
is a regular feature at the Discord
Community um will be held in his name so
I did not know about this wow that's set
it is it is um so
um we are going to save everything else
that we would normally talk about um uh
until after the main part of the episode
uh but for our sponsors we as usual have
three sponsors three ads that we do
right at the top of the show we do not
read ads we not accept uh companies as
sponsors unless we truly vouch for their
products or services and this week we
have not one not two but three sponsors
that are brand new to us and we're
excited about all of them so without
further Ado here we go they are momentus
Maui newie Venison and free spoke and uh
the descriptions and offers are already
in the video description if you're if
you're interested as we're reading these
so
momentus you want to live a long and
prosperous life but longevity isn't
everything it's more important to
consider the number of years that you're
healthy with no chronic or disab or
debilitating disease that's called your
health span and right now in the United
States the average gap between lifespan
and health span is 10 years think about
that people tend to live their last
decade burdened by disease with a poor
quality of life one thing you can do to
increase your health span is to
recognize what you're deficient in and
remedy that our soils are poor and most
of our diets are too plus many of us
live at high enough latitudes we simply
can't generate vitamin D for some months
every year for all of those reasons high
quality supplements can help increase
your health span to that and we want to
introduce you to our first sponsor this
week it's momentus momentus makes
vitamin D which we've been taking we've
begun taking every day from late fall
through early spring when the sun isn't
high enough above the Horizon at high
latitudes in the northern well in either
hemisphere since I just said fall
through spring to generate vitamin D so
supplementation is valuable momentus
also have has zinc and turmeric and a
magnesium 3 and8 that I'm particularly
fond of many of us are low in magnesium
and I find that if I take the Magnesium
from amus a few hours before bedtime my
sleep is particularly deep and restful
momentus also makes an excellent
collagen protein which is made with
grass-fed collagen peptides you can
dissolve it in liquids like smoothies or
coffee or just plain water collagen
protein helps with mental focus and also
muscle and W went joint wellness and
Recovery momentus is an excellent source
for highquality science-backed
rigorously tested supplements of All
Sorts so if you want to take supplements
that are the best available to improve
your health span go to liv.com and use
code that's where Tesla's going right
now he's going to the web he's going to
type in liv.com and use code Dark Horse
for 15% off all their best-in-class
products I'm betting he miss spells it
he probably will yeah he's not a good
speller no no he takes after you that
way wow that's l i v e m o see if he had
waited I would have spelled it for him
that's l i v m o m n t s.com with code
Darkhorse for 15%
off all right our second sponsor this
week is Maui newie ven V that's Maui as
in the Hawaiian island Nei and UI
venison Maui Nei venison is a
mission-based food company bringing the
healthiest red meat on the planet
directly to your door we absolutely love
this meat and its Mission not the
mission of the meat so much but the
mission of the company it is seriously
delicious not gy at all and easy to cook
everything about this company is amazing
and also unusual the meat that they sell
is extraordinary in both taste and
nutritional value and it is both
environmentally and socially responsible
like actually so they're not not just
talking a talk and they're not trying to
satisfy ESG uh claims or anything
responding to the problem of Maui's
invasive Axis deer population Maui Nei
venison is helping to restore balance to
vulnerable ecosystems and communities in
Hawaii by harvesting a limited number of
deer they are seeking to restore balance
to Hawaii not eradicate or Farm these
animals they are limited Maui Nei
venison is limited in how many animals
they can Harvest but more impressive
than that they do so in a stress-free
way wild harvesting fully wild meat in a
complete unique way using
forward-looking infrared technology
to give them what is basically eyes in
the dark they hunt exclusively at night
always with a USDA official in
attendance with such Precision that only
the animals targeted are impacted by the
hunt plus Maui Nei venison has donated
over 16,000 pounds of meat to Hawaiian
communities that have food insecurity
amounting to over 43,000 meals
distributed research at a Utah State
shows that the meat from Maui Nei
venison is the most nutrient dense and
protein dense red meat available this is
nutrition this is nutrition of place the
deer live on volcanic Rich soils which
support remarkable plant diversity and
the deer engage in truly wild grazing
all of which give Maui Nei venison the
highest protein per calorie up to 53%
more than grass-fed beef we H and and
and we got a shipment from them um that
was full of everything from jerky sticks
to bone broth to Fresh Cuts and all of
it all of it is exquisite we highly
recommend trying their allnatural
venison jerky sticks for an optimal
protein snack or their amazing bone
broth or any of their wide variety of
fresh cup all available in their online
butcher shop Maui Nei venison delivers
the healthiest red meat on the planet
directly to your door go to Maui Nei
venisoncooking I should just add we had
a tremendously good conversation with
one of their Founders and pushed them
around a little bit to see whether this
really was um the environmentally
responsible high quality food yeah we
knew it tasted good but we wanted to
know if all the other stories were true
yes and uh I was amazed at the quality
of the answers this really is the real
deal now the stuff is not cheap compared
to the uh high production stuff that
you're buying at the supermarket but
when you realize all of the Corners that
have been cut and all of the
consequences some of them about your
health that fall follow from that corner
cutting you realize that this is
actually extremely high quality food at
a good price for the food exactly
nutrient dense high protein and utterly
delicious yep utterly delicious
absolutely for good reason because your
body can taste that it's good for you
that's right all right our final sponsor
is free spoke now you may be asking
yourself what is free spoke it is not a
bicycle part welfare program no sir it
is a search engine and it is a search
engine that is targeted to solving some
of the very important problems that we
face now a long time viewers of
Darkhorse know that we have talked about
the cartisian crisis which derives from
the fact that we must take almost all of
the information that we have at our
disposal on faith from some Authority
who is often not especially trustworthy
puts us in a position of either becoming
uh overly credulous and believing things
that are not sense or becoming overly or
becoming cynical and not believing
things that we really need to believe so
what are you going to do well I know
that one of the things that I do is I
often look at multiple different sources
that lean different ways to the extent
that all the sources that we have
available to us are biased looking at
multiple sources so that you can correct
for the bias of one by looking at the
bias of the other is a pretty good
solution so that is what free spoke is
about free spoke is a search engine that
attempts to balance out the Viewpoint so
that you can look at the news and figure
out what actually happened and you can
get search uh results that are not based
on Echo Chambers fre spokes vision is
based on several values privacy giving
you anonymous search that's big um all
viewpoints is better than Echo Chambers
and small businesses are the foundation
of our economies and you're going to
love it because every search on free
spoke is anonymous unless you opt into
personalization news is delivered from
across the Spectrum and media bias is
labeled and their shopping search makes
it easier to find americanmade and
Veteran own Brands so check out free
spoke from your desktop or in an App
Store and download it today to make it
your default search engine you can also
look at their about page at free spoke F
[Music]
re.com
slab and be sure to use the code Dark
Horse for whatever you want whenever you
want you don't need it here because this
is absolutely free no code Darkhorse for
free spoke well you still have you can
use the code you know you could speak it
exactly into your first search or
something like that it's it's it's still
a useful code even if it doesn't save
you anything on this excellent free
product yeah um so before we launch into
what we're what we're going to be
talking about today let me say that um
when we when we started doing ads uh in
boy what was it like April of 2021
something like that good year after we
started doing these live streams um we
had been resistant to taking ads uh and
in fact the first episode in which we
ran any paid ads uh we dedicate entirely
to sort of an analysis of why we're why
we're concerned about ads in general uh
and um it's been a very very interesting
run we work with a fantastic ad broker
who is utterly sympathetic to our
position and understands that um you
know in our case most of the
opportunities it brings to us we're
going to say no to and um I don't know I
don't I think it's been almost almost
since then that we've had an episode
with three doe sponsors at once and um
I'm just super thrilled about all of
them so um again free spoke a new kind
of uh search engine uh momentus for
excellent high quality supplements of
all sorts and Maui newie venison for the
most nutrient-dense protein Rich uh V
actually wild and humanely
harvested uh venison on the planet it's
invasive deer brought to Hawaii by King
kameha I 5th I I think that is right yes
yes yeah there's so much in that story
that like just didn't didn't fit into an
adre we'd have to do a whole episode on
it but um yeah invasive deer that are
taking over and they're not trying to
eradicate them they're trying to get
them down to a limit that uh that is
then sustainable and they will only hunt
to that limit and it's it's all
Extraordinary yep all right
uh do you want to talk about Goliath
first or do you want to talk yeah let's
let's let's talk about get this over
with so unfortunately we are still uh in
meshed in the same Saga that we talked
about last time I will say I am
personally in a different place it was
very unpleasant to face some of the push
back and feel like I needed to respond
to all of it which is the way it feels
if you've ever been uh demonized online
you just you see all of the things that
are being said about you that aren't
true and you feel like responding to all
of them I am now I feel like uh I have
moved into the next level of
understanding what is going on and I of
course feel much better about it because
um this is frankly uh about some very
important stuff and the fact that it's
happening is indicative of well the
thing that triggered it when we we
talked about it last time um the thing
that had triggered it was my interview
on Tucker Carlson which reached
something like 6 million people in 3
days and made a couple of um important
points one it uh explored the topic of
the who pandemic preparedness treaty and
it pointed out the danger of the MRNA um
so-called vaccines deployed against
covid and so anyway much push back came
uh but some of it came from a quadrant
which I wasn't expecting which was the
dissident uh movement who many of whom
reacted very badly to my having
said that the um Goliath had made a
terrible error by taking all of the
competent people and demonizing them and
shoving them out of the institutions and
that in so doing he had created uh a
kind of a Dream Team um many people felt
excluded by that statement and I
couldn't figure out why what I'm
realizing now is that
there we have talked about
a strategy that we are vulnerable to
with respect to Goliath and whatever it
is that Goliath wants and that strategy
follows from the fact that Goliath
whatever it is composed of has all of
the intelligence agencies at its
disposal and those intelligence agencies
have something like all of our
communication right they have all of our
text messages our emails our phone calls
and what that means is that if you
wanted to put together a map of let's
say a dissident community and you wanted
to figure out where the tensions were
where the blind spots were where the
resentments were who the people were who
were capable of being corrupted based on
some sort of an incentive if you just
wanted to map all of that out and then
you wanted to destroy destroy the
dissident Community or neutralize it you
would have a very um effective mechanism
for doing so you could simply seed
things into the online world that would
cause people to pop off and go after
each other which is exactly what we are
seeing and what I actually Zach will you
show that uh tweet that uh Paulie put up
I think she put this up the day after uh
that Tucker interview came out um anyway
what she has put together is a and can
you zoom in on the
uh so she's put together a graphic in
which she claims that all of the people
pictured are the new establishment
narrative Gatekeepers and it contains
everybody from Tucker Carlson and Alex
Jones and Russell Brand and Tim p and me
and Douglas Mur and Megan Kelly
and zubie and John Campbell and uh
Robert Malone and then in a separate
category she's got the cross promotion
and she's got you know X and Rumble and
daily wire and rebel news The Blaze Info
Wars she's got uh uh Bobby Kennedy Jr
Vic um and uh Elon Musk as uh somehow
involved and then over in investors musk
again looks like Peter teal Donald Trump
I'm not sure who the fourth person is I
don't recognize him um but in any
case this is somebody I don't know pully
um I take her to be a real person she at
least does videos I'm sure she's not a
completely phony individual my guess is
she's uh a real um a human being but she
has gotten herself in the situation
where she is now calling all sorts of
people um controlled opposition limited
hangout saying that this is what the
establishment wants and she's doing this
in the immediate aftermath of what I
take to be a major setback for the
establishment The Establishment was
trying to get the World Health
Organization to draft new rules that
would give it absolute authoritarian
control over
the populations of most of the countries
of the world in the event of a future
emergency which they so vaguely defined
that it could be anything including
global warming right why if the
establishment why if if I'm on that list
and I go on Tucker Carlson's program and
Tucker's on that list and I out that
plan to a larger audience than had seen
it before that seems like a setback for
Goliath and yet the idea is oh well
that's how it supposed to look you would
say that because you're you're part of
the new establishment and this is
supposed to look like you're a dissident
fighting Goliath but in fact you are
Goliath and it's like well okay first of
all even if you if you just suggest this
as a paradigm right everything that
looks like it's a valid uh challenge to
Goliath is in fact Goliath uh
misdirecting you into something then how
do you even do battle right so so
my point is if you were to imagine that
one of the things that Goliath was going
to do was it was going to play the
resentments and the suspicions of people
within the dissident group of course
there will be suspicions and resentments
and all of that if you were going to
play them and get that group to destroy
itself wouldn't it look exactly like
this yeah I think it wouldn't um and it
reminds me of something else that we
lived through actually I hadn't seen
that tweet before I hadn't seen that
that specific approach that seems quite
explicit at some level uh and of course
there are alternate explanations
possible but um remember
Evergreen the college yeah I do yeah
yeah yeah it's funny my blood pressure
goes
up
um yes so there was this new president
uh who was hired uh to replace the
outgoing president who was actually
Beyond competent you know not beloved by
everyone because he didn't do everything
that everyone wanted but Les Pur had
been a very very qualified president who
left the college stronger than uh it was
when he started and then George Bridges
came in and I'm trying to remember was
it 2015 that he came in 2016 I I think
it has to have been 2015 yeah I think so
too um so it's going to have been fall
of 2015 and one of the very first things
that he
did uh was he said now now guys guys
guys our younger son used to do that
when we were when we were little what
when he was little well all right little
digression so when you have very little
kids right you sort of exaggerate if
you're you're going to get in the car to
go to dinner right you need to get
everybody excited about the thing and so
we would do the guys guys guys thing and
Toby picked that up without the followup
of the announcement that he had gathered
everybody for he just realized that if
he guys
guys yeah so anyway I I George Bridges
was never as cute as Toby I'm sure of
that uh but George Bridges the new the
then new and now gone um president of
Evergreen in the fall of 2015 said guys
guys I've got a friend uh Stan if I
remember correctly and I think he'd been
a geology professor at udub or maybe
still was at University of
Washington and um and the story was uh
was okay we of course can't talk to all
the faculty but I'm going to have Stan
come around and talk to select faculty
and just figure out like what your
aspirations are for the college what you
dream of for the school that I've just
been hired to be at and it's an amazing
and just such a you know such a clearly
glorious place and I'd love to know what
more you think it can be and of course
just that setup means that if you get
the call okay you know can you spare an
hour um you know to spend sitting down
with Stan he'll come to you he'll come
to your office and uh and you know chat
with you in your office um of course it
was the very rare if not the
non-existent faculty who would say I
don't have time for this right um so
Stan came and talked to you and he
talked to me and he talked to well it
turned out we later heard pretty much
everyone right so it wasn't actually a
selective group but you were made to
feel like it was selective because that
was part of how they guaranteed that you
would talk and then in the
conversations it became a little bit
clear and then once we started comparing
notes about all the conversations that
we're having or you know some of us
started comparing notes about what had
been said and what Stan had asked in
these
conversations what he was really doing
was was digging for dirt on
relationships within faculty and between
faculty and staff and I'm not talking
about like romantic Liaisons I'm talking
about where were the Allies where were
the enmities Where were the problems and
the historical feuds and the unresolved
irritations and he effectively mapped us
like the new president came in and
brought his guy who was this you know
esteemed academic from the premier
research institution in the state and
had him sit down with us in just kind of
like a a buddy buddy way and he mapped
our tensions and this then allowed the
new president to use that map of the
social tensions on the Evergreen faculty
and staff to to divide and conquer and
and he went and he went and befriended
the activist faculty and promised them
goodies and anytime anyone would appear
to stray he promised them more goodies
and you know he offered you a bunch of
goodies and you kept saying no much to
his you know surprise and he asked me
what I wanted distress yeah he asked you
what you wanted and at that point I was
on sabatical so he didn't have an
opportunity to ask me what I wanted so
um but yeah he this is what he did he he
used someone to map our social tensions
and um and that map I don't know if what
ended up happening at Evergreen would
have been possible without that map well
I agree entirely with the parallel this
is like a mini Goliath right Evergreen
was a microcosm of all of it it was a
microcosm of the academic Insanity the
uh intersectional nonsense right it was
a microcosm of all of that and then it
became a microcosm of Goliath's divide
and conquer strategy where you had a
faculty which was unusually strong right
administrations usually have a lot of
control over faculty but at Evergreen
that wasn't true and so dividing The
Faculty was necessary in order to
transform the college so by strong you
mean that the faculty had power to to
affect administrative decisions and the
direction of the college in a way that
at most colleges and universities while
it may seem to Outsiders like The
Faculty are driving things and it may
even feel to some faculty like of course
they must be driving things in fact
faculty have almost no power most places
right espe they did especially Junior
faculty who are uh forced to comply with
everything until they've gotten tenure
that was not true at Evergreen and so so
Bridges needed a plan to divide us
against each other in order to be able
to over ride what would otherwise have
been an too often a reflexive veto by
faculty who didn't trust administrators
because they saw it as a mirror of the
uh management versus labor Dynamic right
right that which it never had been right
it never had been and so that was a
blind spot of the faculty but look I
want to tell on myself here because I
see a mirror Beyond just simply what
Bridges pulled on
us I didn't like like Bridges from the
very moment I laid eyes on him I really
did not trust the guy there was
something about him that yeah from
during the hiring process during the
hiring process I really did not want to
see this guy Ascend and I can't remember
there was some couldn't be
avoided when he arrived and he announced
that his friend Stan was going to
interview
US I thought well okay here's this guy
that I really don't trust but he is not
doing the thing that I would fear he was
going to do which is come in and start
changing stuff based on his vision of
the college he is at least listening to
us first and he wants to hear what it is
that's really going on here which would
be important because teaching at
Evergreen if you did it right wasn't
like teaching anywhere else so my sense
was my guard went down as I watched
somebody behave in a way that I thought
was laudable and I felt like okay it is
incumbent on me to give this guy the
benefit of the doubt and I did sit down
with stand and I told him what I thought
because I thought if this guy's going to
play if he's going to be a good
president then I'm going to I'm going to
uh give good information good give him
good information which turns out to have
been a major mistake and the reason that
I say that I'm telling on myself is that
I see and I'm not sure what the
alternative to this is I don't know that
I made an error there obviously in
retrospect given that the guy was a
maniac yeah um I wish I hadn't given him
any information right but I mean I I
just want to specify like neither you
nor I um talked about other faculty
right in those in those conversations um
but we know what the questions were and
we know that other like that he was
constantly asking us to okay but what
you know what about this problem over
here you know in my case he was
specifically focused on like What's
going at the Museum you know you're a
curator there's other curators and like
there there were tensions serious
tensions but like why are you so focused
on that like that was the there were
these bells but well but you
know everything constitutes uh a
weaponized piece of information in this
context even just knowing what a good
classroom looked like and why it worked
right what the relationship with the
Deans was all of that stuff armed him
and it also I think got you and me
selected as targets because it became
obvious in this context that you know we
could stare down pretty much any
challenge to us because we had classes
overflowing with students who almost all
ended up happy at the end of that
process and so there wasn't you know in
a in a in a cash strapped situation that
gave us a lot of leeway to just simply
say no that isn't true it's not how it
works here so anyway but the larger
point is
this I did have suspicions about George
they were right I extended him the
benefit of the doubt at the point that
he indicated something that I thought
was a positive sign and that turned me
into a sucker now the problem is the
alternative to being a sucker in that
case is to be a cynic right and to have
it be impossible for somebody to
demonstrate that they actually are on
the right side and so would I prefer to
be a cynic who you know yes was right
about George the whole time but um would
have been wrong about anybody trying to
do the job correctly no which error do
you prefer to make right and in this
case the point is what is the
presumption right there's a lot of stuff
about covid where obviously this was was
phony baloney from the beginning and I'm
not saying that Co was phony baloney but
the response to it was not well-
intended we now know that because
effectively everything that might have
been useful was shut down and everything
that wasn't useful was promoted and that
can't be an accident that pattern is um
too broad and go ahead well let me just
say I mean we've we started saying at
some point I don't remember exactly when
like literally do the opposite of what
they're telling you to do and you will
be better off even like a static rule is
almost never the right thing to do but
if you just listen to what they say and
you do the opposite you will do better
than than acting randomly certainly that
was not our position at first right
right our position at we we we assumed
at first um that what was coming in um
was reflected everyone's good faith
attempt to make sense of a chaotic and
emerging situation and that was
certainly what we were doing um and it
did not see at that point uh that
everything was wrong because as we
talked about on the last episode you
know we were in favor of masks at first
and very limited lockdowns um but very
quickly they started to make errors that
seemed so grossly negligent was the was
my interpretation at the time not my
interpretation now with regard to you
know not letting people go outside and
putting caution tape on playgrounds and
using bulldozers to fill in skate parks
and chasing people down beaches to to
tell him to get back inside with sick
people or you know whatever like very
very clearly it became it became very
very early became clear but it wasn't
clear from the beginning like we did not
approach it with a everything they say
is wrong because if you approach
anything with a everything X says is
wrong you are going to miss you're going
to miss things and this is this is a
point that we have made many many times
but you know to be completely C
is just as rif with error as it is to be
completely faithful in such a situation
there are still those who if it comes
down the pike from CNN or MSNBC they say
okay it's God God's honest truth and
there are still those who say if it
comes from them it must be wrong now I'm
closer to that second position now but
it's still a matter of assessment and so
skepticism involves assessment whereas
cynicism and Faith say I'm going to set
up a static Rule and I'm just going to
follow that no matter matter what and
that's that's the error it's the error
and the only reason that cynicism worked
in this case was that for whatever
reason the thing on the other side was
committed to a program of doing the
inverse of what was right for the public
yeah and so anyway yes that did end up
being a better rubric and um we would
have been better off if we had all
treated these people with that cynicism
but the problem is you have to decide
what your orientation to a new emerging
situation is is your presumption going
to be that you know the experts are
telling you something real you know
maybe that should no longer be our
expectation we've seen expert class the
expert class um has invalidated their
own expertise by doubling down on
nonsense over the course of multiple
years but was that the correct
orientation at the beginning um my
feeling
is we were
suckers because these people were worse
than we had
imagined we leveled up quickly and well
and that that's what you should do now
my feeling is I I'm
not I recognize that the cynics were
right in this case right they they get a
claim on that rightness people who
leveled up I have no problem with and we
have all leveled up to different places
There's real disagreement over what
actually happened and what it means and
that's healthy right that's what you
want is you want that discussion to have
people who are willing to uh to outline
each of the positions and do so
forcefully so that we can figure out
which ones are the most robust that's
all to the good demonizing each other
however is
insane and what I came to understand in
looking at all of this push back and
thinking carefully about it and
certainly thinking about uh Goliath and
what it might want is that there is this
shocking mirror it's it's it's really
like a mirror it's the exact same thing
on a different topic it this is is Dei
MH right you have a large number of
people who are motivated by resentment
for in their minds not being included
and I'm not saying they were or they
weren't as it was with Dei you and I
said from the beginning is there lots of
unequal opportunity that actually would
be good to remedy absolutely there are
lots of people who are excluded from uh
scientific Fields let's say because of
the ZIP code that they were born in
which put the getting into some field
that they might be very good at that
much farther away and it had nothing to
do with their personal characteristics
it has to do with the misfortune of a
history of Oppression right and in the
same way it may be that there are lots
of people in the dissident Community who
uh paid a price and didn't uh find
themselves rescued by public attention
for reasons of bad luck or reasons of uh
the deafness of some of us I don't know
but but nonetheless a argument for the
redistribution of attention here is a
bunch of people whose faces you know
don't listen to them right they're The
Establishment they're the old white men
right you want to listen to these other
people who are the true blue dissidents
okay that sounds a lot like uh Dei and
what's more it is very focused right so
they've been going after me over uh my
early support of masks and to be honest
with you I'm not exactly sure you know I
certainly thought masks might stand a
chance of being helpful and I certainly
thought uh for adults that they were uh
not a huge concession uh as for mandates
that's a different question but
nonetheless even though I have many
times publicly said my stance on masks
was wrong I have acknowledged that and
other people had it right they are not
interested in the fact that I have
corrected the error their point is we're
not satisfied until you deliver an
apology which sounds exactly like this
mob mentality and let me just be clear
about this correcting my errors is my
responsibility in this case here is why
apology is a completely inappropriate
thing to
demand some of you will remember I've
discussed the first lesson I ever gave
as a professor the first assignment
which was to write on the question of
why an apology works it's just people
saying stuff vibrating air molecules why
if you've been injured by somebody does
them saying I'm sorry I injured you have
any material meaning at all it doesn't
uninjure you does it well yeah it does
in in a couple of different ways one if
somebody harms you um and they
acknowledge it then a they are making it
much harder for them to make that same
mistake later because they are making I
cont with it B and more importantly they
are giving you effectively an IOU you
were damaged by something I did and
therefore I am in your debt my apology
is a debt now here's the
point I have corrected my error I have
made eye contact with what I did wrong
does it make it impossible I will do it
wrong again nope but it does make it
more likely because I have consciously
been through it a hundred times do I owe
you an apology because I've injured you
no because if you look at the sum total
of what you and I did over the course of
covid at the same time where we were too
credulous on the question of whether or
not masks might function we were
shouting at the top of our lungs about
the fact that it made no sense to be
keeping people out of outdoor
environments or masking them Outdoors
that never made any sense to us you and
I built a model of um the effective
volume of a space as it related to the
transmissibility of covid which meant
that you could actually adjust your
behavior if you were getting into a car
the danger to you was much greater if
you were in a large Auditorium the
danger was much less if you open the
windows in the car the danger goes down
so the point is if you take all of the
things that we talked about if we take
our assessment of the safety of the
so-called vaccines if you take our
analysis of uh what kinds of behaviors
might make you safer being outside
getting sun exposure supplementing with
vitamin D Etc if you take the net of all
of the stuff we did you ended up way
better off and so in demanding an
apology it is like saying imagine that
some Army was fighting a great battle
against some terrible enemy and it won
the war
but it lost some battles does that Army
owe you an apology for the battles it
lost no the net effect of that Army was
positive on you there were things maybe
those battles were lost because of
errors that were made still apology is
the wrong thing to be demanding so my
point is the net effect of the divisions
inside the dissident Community will be
to embolden and Empower Goliath no
question about it are there some limited
Hangouts and controlled opposition in
the dissident Community I'd be shocked
if there weren't it would be a crazy
error for Goliath not to have seated
that Community with a certain amount of
that stuff but let's be clear we don't
know who those people are and you know
peeking into every statement or claim
and imagining that you can see this
stuff you can't you might see it as a
result of a pattern of things but well I
mean to the degree that the that the
complaints here are honest and organic
and
real I think it does also reveal this
position that many of us feel that we're
in which is this just
this this crazy making moment which has
now gone on for years which forces you
to question just about every
relationship you have how did they come
into my life how long have I known them
what have they said what have they known
that surprised me what haven't they
known that surprised me what are the
chances that they are who they say they
are this is no way to live this is
absolutely no way to live a life it's
exhausting and it makes you paranoid and
it makes you seem like a crazy person so
are you know are other people also
finding themselves having to do this yes
no doubt of course and will absolutely
honest and honorable actors in you know
in this landscape uh find themselves
questioned yes obviously and you know
and you are being and I have been and
you know and there are there are many
others um who who have been and will be
um who don't actually deserve that but
you you have to you you have to look
skeptically at the entire landscape in
order to have some chance of discovering
who those people who are actually acting
as controlled opposition and such might
be
um that said it's pointed not only I can
say for sure that I know that you're not
that and this is actually so I I
recorded a a podcast yesterday and he
and he asked the very last question
Johan Newman asked me was um what to
what do you
attribute the length of your
relationship our
relationship our ability to do what we
appear to do and have been doing for
decades um presuming that as all people
um as all two people have we have
conflicts we have arguments uh we get
emotional we feel betrayed when we're
not we feel betrayed when we we are like
all of these things are true and one of
the things that I said
was for you know since Evergreen
basically but since before that actually
um we have had to question so many
people whom we thought we knew who
turned out to not be who we thought and
then we have welcomed in so many new
people into our world most of whom have
turned out to be extraordinary but you
can't ever know if they're new right
like you you if you don't have the
history there is no replacement for
having the history with someone and that
no matter what no matter you know how
difficult a time you and I may be having
personally which is not that common but
of course it happens we know that we are
who we say we are we are true you are
true I am true and we are true to one
another but I'm not talking about
loyalty here I'm talking about we've
known each other since we were young we
met at 16 y right so there is just no
and and so you know that that is part of
why that is part part of why these these
movements like black lives matter are so
dangerous when they say we're going to
try to tear apart the nuclear family
like who else am I utterly sure of my
children right our children you know
they they may end up you know believing
things that we don't understand that we
wish they didn't they may end up doing
things that we wish they didn't but we
know who they are and we know who they
have been from the beginning and even
though I haven't known you since
birth I know I know you and I know that
these accusations are you know to the
extent that they are good faith they are
wrong and to the extent that they are
themselves part of Goliath or controll
opposition or whatever well then we can
see you or we can at least interpret
that that is one possibility of what is
happening here yeah I mean
uh I would
say you have to be open to the
possibility I don't even mind the
question right if somebody says Hey how
do I know you're not controlled
opposition I'm perfectly comfortable
having that discussion with them and you
know I will lean heavily on if I were
controlled opposition um how does that
map onto what you can establish yourself
origin story as far as being in the
public eye what you know what I have
stood for and how you think that fits
with what uh Goliath would want me to be
doing right so we you know we can narrow
it down and I'm I'm um comfortable with
the idea that I can be 100% certain I
can't be certain that I'm not being
steered by some force that feeds me
things that cause me to act in ways that
are in violation of my values that could
be um but I'm not a willing participant
on Goliath's team right I don't get a
paycheck from Goliath and I take myself
to be Goliath's enemy so anyway but you
you know I know that you don't know that
um but you can have an estimate about
the likelihood that that's true and my
guess is for most people especially if
you know me in person but even if you've
just spent a lot of time watching
Darkhorse or you know interviews with
other
people it's pretty unlikely that Goliath
would come up with me as a fake human um
but here's the thing you
mentioned the experience of uh people
disappointing Us and other people um
shining in crisis and I realized over
the last few days that that was
happening again and I hate it right that
crisis does this I've called it the
painful upgrade where um people you
thought you could rely on you can't and
then people show up out of nowhere that
um surprise you and the net effect of
this is very positive but the pain of
discovering that somebody you thought
you could trust isn't trustworthy is uh
quite severe yeah and I would just say
that you know this is happening right
now on both fronts right we are seeing
people who absolutely should know
better you know it it's tempting to
point a few of them out um but my guess
is you know who you are right there are
a bunch of people who you know there are
disagreements that we have inside of the
dissident Community um you know there
are people who believe there was no
pathogen I know what evidence they're
looking at I don't agree with them but
the point is that's not a we can either
you know either Co was uh made to look
much more dangerous than it was or we're
talking about some other pathogen or
there was no pathogen I'm open to that
possibility but in any case people um
have turned these disagreements into
fundamental critiques about uh the
quality of one's character and they've
started using litmus tests and this
again is exactly what goliath would want
whether or not Goliath is behind it I
can't say for sure but my guess is given
Goliath's history disrupting
organizations from uh the Civil Rights
Movement the Black Panthers um the
environmental movement uh Occupy Wall
Street the Tea Party all of these things
there's a history of getting movements
to turn on themselves and of course it
would be doing that now so we should be
expecting it now on the positive side I
wanted to highlight actually there's one
negative and one positive
um the positive side somebody alerted me
to a piece that Scott Adams did in a uh
in I think yesterday's coffee with Scott
Adams and I haven't checked in with
Scott Adams in a long time we had some
disagreements um during covid about what
was going on and then at some point he
said something uh which I I still quite
disagree with he said something uh um in
the context of a battle over race
relations that basically one side was
cheating and he advised uh white people
to get away from darkskinned people um
now I know what he meant and the reason
I disagreed with him about that was that
I feel like we have an obligation to
take care of those um who you know dark
skinned people who aren't playing Dei
are in need of our Allegiance and so
anyway I didn't think it was simple but
Scott did a uh segment in his recent um
coffee with Scott Adams that he covered
the push back on the Tucker Carlson uh
discussion that I had and he also o
covers uh he covers the mass question
and he talks about it from a um risk
management perspective anyway I was
impressed with the quality of what he
said not just that he was supportive
which is of course nice but um but the
quality of his analysis and his
willingness to push back on his own
audience actually some of which was
reflexive in their um dismissal of this
yeah he I was just say I haven't
listened to to all of it and he does say
okay you now I'm going to spend some
time critiquing
um and so he's you know he's he's very
forthright and honest but
um he says you need more Brett and he
salutes your ability to explain
complicated things and your bravery and
your dedication to following the data
where where it takes you um and that's
that you know I I of course agree um I
mean I get a lot of you but I still
still think the world needs more bre you
don't need more bread but other people
might uh yeah and it it was it was just
it was truly heartening um to see this
this this bit from him yeah it was uh it
was good now I did want to clarify one
thing um I wasn't sure the little push
back that he gave was somebody
challenged me online um how they
couldn't figure out how anybody educated
as I was could possibly have thought
that a mask would stop a virus given the
relative size of the holes in the mask
and the tininess of the virus and I
responded I said riddle why would
anybody think that um you could uh
affect the spread of malaria with a
window screen given the size of the
holes in the window screen and the size
of uh the plasmodium particle and some
people didn't understand that I wasn't
challenging the effectiveness of windows
screens relative to malaria that I was
pointing out that there's more going on
the fact that the malaria viruses aren't
traveling through the air um unattached
to other things they're traveling
through respiratory droplets right and
so in the case of malaria traveling on
an insect in the case of uh covid it's
traveling on a water droplet but it's
not a simple matter of the size of the
hole and the size of the of the pathogen
um and at first I thought that Scott had
misunderstood what I said but then he
seemed to correct course so anyway if if
anybody was confused by this what I was
trying to say was welcome to complex
systems sometimes the size of a and the
size of B isn't the story because
there's some third party you see that is
relevant from uh non-pathogen
land we have a few
colanders and uh one of them has pretty
big holes and yet it collects spaghetti
just fine like occasionally you'll get a
piece of spaghetti that hits it just
right and and can go through but in
general um because of the shape of the
of the thing even though its diameter
may be smaller than the holes in the
vessel that doesn't mean that mostly it
goes through yeah that's a good point
that's a good point rice not so good
yeah R you want to use a strainer right
the calendar you do um but okay so
anyway um really appreciated it actually
I didn't when somebody pointed me to the
Scott Adams thing I didn't pick up that
uh his discussion of me was very late in
the coffee thing so I listened to the
whole thing which was actually really
interesting um Scott has a pretty uh
Advanced perspective politically across
the whole map he covers multiple topics
and I thought it was well worth a listen
so we'll post it in the show notes yeah
so anyway um uh appreciate appreciated
the support and appreciated the Nuance
in what Scott had to say on the opposite
side of the spectrum I was also pointed
to um David Pacman David Pacman who
reacted to the Tucker interview and put
up his own little video um taking me to
task and using this very unfortunate
screenshot but um anyway um
Pacman because of course he did of
course he did well I don't know where
that screenshot came from so it's POS
sometimes YouTube picks stuff that's
weird but let's put that aside David um
is of course scandalized by my having
referenced Dennis rainc Court's work
suggesting 17 million deaths so far from
Co
vaccination and
uh he goes through a bizarre in my
opinion um refutation of rain courts
number rain Court uh explores the
question of excess deaths and the timing
relative to uh waves of covid and uh
vaccination campaigns and he shows uh
what I I don't think it's conclusive but
I think it's uh quite compelling
evidence that the timing suggest that
the excess deaths are not the result of
Co and are the result of uh the
vaccination
campaign
um
Pacman refutes this and he acknowledges
that he's playing with anecdotes here
but he goes through a rhetorical
interchange with his audience who he
can't hear answering but his point was
um does anybody know anyone who had a
serious vaccine
injury no I don't think maybe one or two
of you do but almost nobody does so he's
just talking to himself yeah does
anybody know anybody an anecdote that's
pretending to be anecdote right it's
like a pseudo thought anecdote and I
will say uh I saw your thing I'm in your
audience I guess David I know lots of
people who were hurt actually you know
some of them you don't know others and
I'm not going to out them but yeah the
number of people who I know who actually
did have a serious adverse event
including of are still hiding that fact
because somehow being injured is now
itself a crime you it's a moral crime to
have been injured by something the
government told you to take what's more
somebody uh who was a friend of mine got
an injury and I interviewed him about it
and that's on Darkhorse so this is
somebody I didn't pick him because he
was injured he and I uh knew each other
before he was injured he believed the
shots were a good idea got one was
severely injured um then got him to a
doctor who knew how to treat his injury
and he's much better but nonetheless the
number of people in our Circle who do
have a serious injury and the number of
famous well I mean so the you know the
thing that will come back there is
because we are people who have been
talking about the lack of of safety and
efficacy of these vaccines of course we
will collect such stories and that that
is also true but we know people many
people whom we knew before Co ever
existed um who have been vaccine injured
that's right people who we knew then
then that really is a measure yeah yeah
you can't you can't use the other
because it could just be an uh an
attractor but um but no the number of
people that we know we knew beforehand
who have a serious injury is substantial
and if you don't David my guess is and I
I've said this before you need to ask
the question in such a way that people
will give you the answer if you go
around demonizing people who talk about
vaccine injuries and then you say by the
way anybody got one yeah no kidding
those people won't be in your audience
at a very high level and they won't be
in your Social Circles and if they are
in your Social Circles they're going to
be quiet about it because you're asking
them to out themselves as the
enemy um and I think the thing that is
very difficult to talk about um well to
to get appreciation for is how many
people we know and how many other people
we know who in turn know many people who
are vaccine injured and are not out even
many in many of their cases to their
families to their employers to their
friends who are skeptical that anyone is
getting injured so again it's this it's
considered a moral failing you just as
it used to be just as you know being a
woman in Victorian era in Victorian
times was a moral failing of some sort
right it is considered a moral failing
by people like David Pacman um to have
been vaccine injured that is diabolical
but what that does do is it changes the
behavior of those people who have been
vaccine injured not all of them by any
means um but but it is certain we know
some of these people and we know many
others by reputation by you know two
degrees of separation um that many
people who have been injured and who are
able to obscure it in some way try to
pass and they are successful in passing
and yes it's not the usual context in
which you hear passing referred to but
there are a lot of people out there
right now who are passing as being
vaccinated and being just fine but no
more boosters thank you very
much but actually what went into that
decision to not take any more boosters
was the fact that they were injured by
the previous
iteration
um yes he has got a
self-reinforcing uh
pattern um it does not
match what one sees uh from a different
perspective lots of injured people he
then goes on to use so rainc Court looks
at many different countries and looks at
the independent uh data sets of deaths
which are very
uh um studiously recorded in all nations
or virtually All Nations and Pacman
thinks he refutes it based on his
thought experiment which is deeply
flawed um he says he knows nobody who
was vaccine injured and he knows several
people who died from covid now I would
point out chances that the people he
knows that quote unquote died of covid
were also vaccinated and therefore you
have to ask the question of what were
the factors that contributed to their
death is high
and uh given how many people are
asymptomatic when testing positive for
covid and given how many people have
been very very sick while never testing
positive for covid covid is clearly a
fellow traveler for some people and many
cases that have been attri many deaths
that have been attributed to co were not
of covid but with Co but with Co which
is something rain Court covers very
carefully um
finally going from raint study which
covers many different
nations Pacman claims to refute it on
the basis of a pattern he says took
place in Peru now I watched ranc Court's
presentation ranc court is very careful
to point out those circumstances in
which a pattern goes goes in the other
direction I suggest David Pacman have
Dennis rainc court on and they can have
this out if if David if you think you've
got this analysis beat then you should
definitely have Dennis rainc court on
and you can humiliate him and the world
will know that this uh these excess
deaths are not the result of the vaccine
campaign and you will have done a lot of
good in your in your mind I don't think
that's what's going to
happen and finally I would just say
Pacman at the very end of his little
piece says that he is um that five years
ago he would have thought I was too
smart to fall for the idea that these um
vaccines are causing substantial excess
deaths and now he's caught between two
possibilities one possibility is that
I'm lying and the other is that I don't
get it and he has a little debate he
says lying is worse but these things are
both horrifying so he has that little
debate with himself yeah let me clarify
this for him I'm not lying David and I
don't think you know what you're talking
about so I suggest have Dennis ranc
court on I'm not saying Dennis ranc
Court's number is right but I do think
it's credible I think the methodology is
valid and um the nature of excess deaths
is that one has to infer based on other
evidence what would be causing them
which rain court is careful about so if
you if you think youve got this one
nailed then show
us all right all right um I had one
other thing which I think we just have
to pay the rent on we showed a clip on
uh Wednesday of a podcaster who took me
to task falsely for having
claimed um Jewish genetic superiority
right um we pointed out that I had never
said that I don't believe it and um to
his credit he checked into the matter
and apologized and corrected the record
fantastic fantastic but then well no no
this isn't on him I don't know I don't
know what's going on but you want to
show the uh um the screenshot from
Foster so he corrected the record I
thanked him for it publicly next thing I
see from him says YouTube has now
deleted all my videos from my channel
without notice or Reason take this as a
a sign that I'm doing the right thing
now let us talk about what predicament
we are in I don't know if this guy is
for Real yeah yeah this obviously could
be a ploy but it could also be next
level Chess By Goliath yeah right this
could be if
you
wanted to make it look like I was on
Goliath
team then removing this guy's videos in
the aftermath of that exchange might
make it look like that
now again I don't know what's going on I
don't know you know it's a Hall of
Mirrors so take it for what it's worth
um but in my opinion one should act with
generosity towards dissidents one should
have forgiveness in their hearts if
people level up but there are a lot of
people who are taking taking themselves
off the Dream Team nobody's excluding
them they're taking themselves off the
Dream Team by deciding that you know
it's a an exclusive club and that they
get to decide you know who is
sufficiently Hardcore to be on it my
feeling is anybody who's trying to do
the right thing has courage and insight
is on the team and you don't get thrown
off for honest
errors yeah and uh hardcore does not
come with cynicism and certainty
cynicism and certainty actually are are
going to occasionally yield the right
answers but uh in general are going to
make for a less uh flexible less
powerful toolkit with which to
understand the world
yep should we uh should we move on yeah
let's move
on G to talk about
Boeing boing boing and the FAA and Dei
and other um letters and apparently
random but not actually that random
orders very good all right um okay so
everyone will know have heard about this
Alaska airflight out of Portland uh that
um some small number of minutes after
takeoff it was I think three miles up uh
a mid cabin door blew out just uh just
after takeoff uh both seats next to the
door were unoccupied uh everyone in the
plane
survived uh and in the aftermath the F
FAA has grounded several
inlight departure if a mid cabin door
plug inlight departure departure yes
very odd turn of phrase which resulted
in a rapid decompression of the airplane
the FAA is issuing this airiness
directive to address the potential
in-flight loss of a mid cabin door plug
which could result in injury to
passengers and crew the door impacting
the airplane and or loss of control of
the airplane there that is all written
about some uh hypothetical future event
although it clearly did just happen
which is why this EAD is happening uh
and yes the inflight departure
unauthorized departure of the from the
flight did not take a hall pass no
exactly didn't get a hall pass was uh
and and yeah so okay so that's what the
um that's what they're responding to and
so can can I say a few things about this
event first maybe you're headed here
um let me just say a couple more things
first um the EAD it's sort of a long
technical document but another thing it
says is um this emergency air worthiness
directive as issued by the FAA on
January 6
6 sixth sixth quote requires operators
to inspect affected aircraft before
further flight the required inspections
will take around 4 to8 hours per
aircraft and the EAD will affect
approximately 171 airplanes worldwide uh
so unfortunately one of the downstream
effects of this of course is that Alaska
airs stock is is going down and this has
nothing nothing to do with Alaska right
this is Boeing this is about Boeing
having create having produced a bunch of
aircraft and this is not the first time
that this particular model of aircraft
has come under scrutiny for maintenance
and safety issues uh and uh you know
Alaska happens to have been the UN you
know unfortunate carrier where there was
an incident but it was about the plane
being one of these Boeing 7379 Max
planes not the fact that it was Alaska
and I say that I cannot believe that I'm
a fan of any Airline but Alaska is um
you know hubs out of Seattle and uh
We've Ended up flying a lot of airlines
in the last few years and Alaska is
heads above above every other carrier
and so you know I just feel bad for them
that they happen to have been the one um
that was that that had the air um the
door take an unexcused absence from the
plane um and so then on January 11th uh
a couple days later um they oh wait wait
I I want to talk about the incident
itself but they say this incident should
have never happened and it cannot happen
again and uh and I lost the rest of the
statement so um go for it okay there are
some facts about this that people should
understand one from the inside of the
plane it was not apparent that there was
even a door there okay this is a door
door plug it's this is a door that is
built in so that you can have a door
there if you want and on the Alaska
versions of this plane that door from
the inside of the plane just looked like
another window seat M
um which is why there were seats sitting
right next to it right right because we
don't no there there are lots of exit
rows that have a seat right next to them
um that's true
the the important thing about this is
that because this happened right after
takeoff I think they were you said 3 mil
up I think it was 10,000 some odd feet
up but anyway anyway whatever maybe I
have that wrong nonetheless it wasn't 30
plus th000
ft and what that
means is two things one 3 miles 4.8
kilm okay 7 minutes after takeoff so
a the pressure differential between the
inside and the outside of the plane was
much lower than it would ultimately have
been which has was at an altitude at
which people can breathe without
assistance right absolutely absolutely
um so but that also means that the
violence of the unexcused absence of
this
door um was much reduced yet it still
pulled seats out of the plane I don't
think that happened you think that
happened no I don't I don't find any
evidence that that happened oh okay well
the two seats nearest the door plug um
that departed without without the due
author
um were empty uh and there were there
were no mortality there was no mortality
in think even no injuries on the plane
but I I don't think any seats got okay
well maybe I maybe I misunderstood that
part but the point is the violence of
the decompression was much lower than it
would have been and also that means that
the stress necessary to push this plug
out of the wall of the plane was lower
than it might have been too so the
degree to which This Plane had been
compromised and nobody had known about
it was uh much greater than you would
imagine because it took much less of a
differential impr pressure to blow the
door out um so you can understand I mean
I in my
opinion I don't know that the FAA isn't
going to have some responsibility for
having licensed This Plane um in a form
where such things could
happen um but the FAA did the right
thing grounding these planes right they
need to all be inspected because to the
extent that something that could blow
this plug out at that low altitude uh
was capable of doing it yes that could
be a fluke something that happened to
one plane but you know there's a reason
that air travel is as safe as it is and
that's because checks are thorough and
things are built fail safe and you know
whatever cracks they're ultimately going
to find or whatever it is you know
cracks in something bad rivets I don't
know but yep um whatever it was should
have been noticed many times before this
was able to happen there should have
been you know and in fact there was I
think something about a pressure light
having fired multiple times indicating
that there was some breach that should
have resulted in
um in uh an
inspection so uh 171 planes are grounded
until they uh undergo 4 to8 Hour um
safety checks
worldwide um but that is all what it
is
but now there's a Kur fuffle a a hubub
generated um because James Lindsay
Unearthed some documents from Boeing uh
that suggest that maybe we actually
could have kind of seen this coming and
I'm going to start however with uh the
Elon Musk tweet uh in which he quote
tweets Jim um James uh because that of
course is what got the attention then of
the mainstream media who are trying to
downplay this so we're going to walk
through first what mus says about what
Lindsay says and what the mainstream
media says about musk before going into
some of the nitty-gritty of what Lindsay
has actually Unearthed so um here is the
Tweet by musk do you want to fly in an
airplane where they prioritize Dei
hiring over your safety that is actually
happening and that is a quote tweet of
the initial tweet in Lindsay's thread
which we're going to look at a little
bit um more later but uh the initial
tweet of of James's is let's have a
close look at Boeing and de EI Boeing's
corporate filings with the SEC revealed
that in the beginning of 2022 the annual
bonus plan to reward CEO and Executives
for increasing profit for shareholders
and prioritizing safety was changed to
reward them if they hit Dei targets and
specifically here is it's a Boeing proxy
statement 2022 proxy statement in which
in
2021 Executives uh were their
operational performance um areas that
they were being looked at that were
being looked at were product safety
employee safety and quality and those
did not disappear in 2022 but they were
added to so now you also have climate
and diversity equity and
inclusion okay so we had three areas by
which um by which Executives at Boeing
were being assessed in 2021 and in 2022
that has changed we've got two more
areas climate and Dei if I if I'm
ISAC
um the mainstream
media basically says in response to
this how could musk be so crass and
ridiculous right how you know what what
actually is he is he doing uh so we have
at Baron there's a number of these um
these articles of course um but we have
here at Barons Elon Musk says Boeing has
a diversity problem the evidence says
otherwise uh let's see if I can find uh
a particularly
remarkable paragraph here we go starting
here musk's tweet is also misleading
safety is still used to determine
bonuses sadly this is a quote now as a
key International figure an icon musk is
being
inflammable like that and taking the Dei
out of context says Kristen Hull founder
of Nia impact Capital quote again if you
look at the bonus incentive the language
is adding Dei as an additional Focus
Criterion not taking away focus on
safety it's not either or said the woman
who called musk
inflammable I you know apparently she
has neither linguistic nor quantitative
skills right so like you had three
things that they were being assessed on
and now you have
five unless these Executives were
working at 60% capacity and they just
had a lot more room to do a lot more
stuff and therefore you can just add
more stuff in and not take away from the
stuff that they were doing in which case
those are some pretty overpaid
Executives I would think and they needed
to have some better Executives there in
the first place if these Executives were
actually working at full capacity which
we generally expect Executives of major
corporations to
do you add two more things to a list
that was only three long of things that
they are going to be incentivized to be
excellent at and what's going to suffer
the other things that they were supposed
to be focusing on which again was
product quality and employee quality and
I believe it was safety obviously so you
have pointed to one obvious trade-off
cost here that to the extent that you
have added an extra criteria you expect
a decrease in the success on the other
criteria to drop unless uh the thing was
fatally underperforming to begin with
but here's the other thing is in this
case there's a very specific reason it
isn't just that you've added something
else that would be nice to accomplish
but that to to accomplish a diversity
equity and inclusion goal implies hiring
different people than we'll get there
but my point is that's two distinct
tradeoff reasons that you should expect
this problem to happen
well given what this given what the
standards are we don't yet know how it
is that they're going to happen right
like so I'm I'm I'm trying to just be
very clear like this this Christen Hull
character who apparently has tried to
give musk grief in the past I don't know
if he if she's aat in his world or he
doesn't know who she is at all or if
she's actually a player um but given
that there's just you know five areas
now we don't know how any of them are
being are being implemented we don't
actually know you know product safety
employee safety quality were the areas
before and now we've got climate which I
assume means like global climate and we
have no idea you know this is Boeing how
what are they going to do they've got a
climate problem right um and then
diversity Equity inclusion now probably
and we will see actually from James's
further uh Research into this I'll show
you a couple things um how they're going
to do that is by hiring
disproportionately based on um
demographic characteristics as opposed
to based on Merit in which case
obviously safety and product quality and
probably or product safety and employee
safety and quality are going to take a
hit um but given that we don't know
given they don't specify uh we we all we
can say from this from what we are what
we are seeing right right here is
actually if you had three standards that
you were being assessed on and now
you've got five unless you were
underperforming rap like unless you were
wildly underperforming before those
three initial standards will be done to
a lower level now well I I disagree with
you a little bit
because if you had
discrimination in Boeing's hiring policy
then actually you could increase both
diversity equity and inclusion and Merit
at the same time but absent that because
you had discrimin I don't understand you
discriminating against French people
every so often a French person is going
to be the most qualified person for the
job and some fraction of the time they
should get the job they won't and so you
won't have the best people in the job
the best people in the job comes from a
completely
colorblind uh and sex blind application
process in which Merit is the only thing
that causes you to get hired okay so and
you may find afterwards I don't know why
you would at a company like Boeing um
but you may find afterwards oh we've got
an over representative of French people
right or it's the NBA we've got an over
representative of tall people and the
tall people are often the darker skinned
people and we weren't trying to do that
we swear that's what happened yeah we're
trying to win games and it resulted in a
non random sample of the population okay
so my point is look if there was
discrimination that's bad for Mar if
there was no discrimination then Dei is
bad for merit because what it does is it
forces you to add other considerations
that then compete with Merit and that
means you don't have the best people
designing uh door plugs for airplanes so
I think we can infer I think we can
infer and in fact you know the evidence
that James outlines allows us to do that
but I don't think we even need to go to
the inference level because I think
there's a more basic there's a
fundamental math math thinking error
happening here and it's apparently being
made by someone who is uh what is she
the founder of Nia impact Capital like I
don't know what that is I didn't look
into it but that sounds like someone who
has some skills and knows some things
and um and the point that you are making
a requires inference and is a little bit
more abstract like maybe I get why some
people aren't going to get that but the
actually you had three things and now
you have five yes some among the
original Three are going to suffer
unless you were underperforming to such
a degree that you could add these and
not take anything from the first three
well I don't see any reason not to put
them both on the table especially in
light of the fact that the intersection
lists pretend that the world
is um postmodern therefore what would
Merit even be in relation to they
pretend that these skills aren't real
things and so they discount the
possibility that by prioritizing
something other than than Merit that
you're going to compromise all of these
functional systems on which we depend
which would of course be a very forceful
argument uh against their nonsense so I
think it's you know as somebody who has
studied and thought a lot about
tradeoffs both of these things are
clearly uh clearly hazards and you know
again the
also what was the phraseology for what
they're
prioritizing um the climate and
oh the the actual things that they're
now prioritizing are that's a different
one we had originally product safety
employee safety and quality and now
we've got climate and it's Dei it's
diversity equity and inclusion so then
even the phraseology diversity equity
and inclusion is an uh illusion to a
very specific perspective it's not
anti-discrimination it is specifically a
um a
affirmative
correction that in this case is going to
compete with uh design so they're
they're invoking Dei means we can infer
that they are not talking about getting
rid of discrimination they are talking
about working to be inclusive in an
environment where Merit is obviously
relevant to safety I think I'm pushing
back against this because this requires
inference
and I know you're right I I know that
this is actually the effect and in fact
again as I'm about to show you the the
other evidence that Jim has put together
demonstrates that the stuff in the
details is like proves that this is
actually how Dei manifests but at the
most simple level at a level that anyone
should be able to understand if you've
got Baron's and a lot of other
mainstream articles that I found just
saying musk was clearly wrong how dare
he he's a awful racist Tycoon right you
know they're just it's it's all the same
stuff over and over again and you have
someone who is charted out as as
powerful you know founder of whatever it
was Nia impact Capital right who makes
such an a mind bogglingly basic mistake
of simple logical reasoning that that
can be pointed out whereas what you were
just talking about is you know maybe
more important ultimately and definitely
true
but harder to explain and you and people
will get lost in those details and they
will want to get lost in these details
and I guess part of what I'm trying to
do is say you know what when you had
three things that you needed to focus on
and now you have five those original
Three will suffer unless you were
underperforming it's can you said that
simply yeah the other problem though and
I know you're headed here that you you
did the work to to find it but we have
predicted this outcome and because we
predicted this outcome on the basis that
diversity and equity and inclusion would
come at the expense of Merit right this
second kind of uh dangerous
compromise well why don't we just look
at the actual evidence so so what you're
doing is requiring inference and I don't
think it's necessary because there's
actual evidence of this okay well but a
prediction that manifests potentially
we'll get to the prediction too like yes
we predicted that this would happen um
but that the having three er is go to
Five um yes will result in what you're
talking about but that requires analysis
and care and um and this does not so
this um is another of the documents that
James Lindsay Unearthed a letter from
leadership progress isn't a moment in
time and it's not a set of set of
metrics progress is commitment and
action from all all of us every day this
is from 2023 Boeing Global Equity
diversity and inclusion
report
1 two 3 four five fifth um paragraph in
which the the stuff in red are have been
blocked bracketed out by James but I'm
going to read this whole paragraph also
in 2022 for the first time in our
company's history we tied incentive
compensation to
inclusion there it is okay our goal was
to achieve diverse interview slates for
at least 90% of manager and executive
openings I don't know what a diverse
interview slate is okay we exceeded that
Target with 92% of interview slates
being diverse resulting in 47% diverse
hires at the management and executive
levels at the point you're over 50%
isn't the opposite diversity but okay um
for 2023 we've raised the bar and expect
at least 92.5% of those interview slates
will be
diverse people are so insane ESG is
driving um but I mean like Ser among
everything else wrong with this they
made 92% and they're going to raise the
bar and go to 92 and a half half
perc like what a climb what what like
the goal is notable it's anti- lble and
they're like we're g to keep on going
but just this tiny little bit well but
wait hold we do not just one last
sentence here we do this not to hit a
certain number like yes you do we do
this not to hit a certain number but
because meritocracy demands the
opportunity to compete wow so like they
just like they're just claiming the
opposite of what they're doing they're
claiming that this is in service of
meritocracy when it cannot be and that's
back to your point yep now I would also
point out that the achievement in quotes
of whatever they 92% diverse interview
slates that was their target uh no their
target was 90 90 and their new Target
will be 92.5 okay so but my point is
going to be what people are not going to
spot is that this is clearly a
diminishing returns realm where the
point is those those fractional
advantages that come very late are going
to come at spectacular cost right as you
try to increase the diversity of your
slates you know you've worked hard
you've gotten everybody who could
possibly apply and you're going to work
that much harder that means that the
compromises are actually expected to be
large for these little gain that's what
diminishing returns is that's right get
little gains at huge cost so again to to
that point and also to to the point that
putting Dei as something by which your
Executives will be compensated will
inherently cause a decrease in in
quality and in and in those other things
that presumably are what helped make you
a global Corporation in the first place
the final paragraph again from the 2023
Boeing Global Equity diversity and
inclusion report progress is every
teammate acting on our seek speak and
listen
habits progress is every teammate
feeling physically and psychologically
safe and ensuring that safety for each
other and ensuring that safety for each
other progress is reflecting the
diversity of the world's Talent within
our Workforce progress is being the
destination for great people to build
amazing careers in Aerospace not the
best people but great people progress is
equity progress is diversity progress is
inclusion for all and by all what are
they going to hire all eight billion of
us like what even is the claim here and
you know right there like okay is this
the
Equity diversity inclusion report but
their measures of progress don't say
anything about quality or safety nothing
at all except um feel feeling physically
and psychologically safe they are
prioritizing the feelings of their new
great Workforce but not the actual
safety of that Workforce or its
customers or the quality of the products
that they are making it is unfortunately
even worse than that because what this
is is the
transportation of the rules that are
being instituted inside the student
level of participation in colleges into
a corporate environment where your and
my safety is being
determined and when they say everybody
needs to feel safe what they mean
is um certain people will not have the
right to critique other people right and
here's my problem
let's say you have some annoying
impolite white guy who uh has a be in
his Bonnet about a broken calculation or
a manufacturing process he's a little
spectrum and he kind of uh makes one of
the women uncomfortable because he asked
her out once and it was awkward or Worse
he's going to say something that makes
the person who's making the error look
dumb right he's not sensitive so she's
not going to feel safe or he's not going
to feel safe and and the point is you
need to have in in a especially in a
safety context you need to have
something where somebody who's got an
actual observation to make about errors
that are being made or opportunities
that are being missed or processes or
whatever it is those people have to be
emboldened and protected in saying that
you can't do this if you do this in a
Dei context then what you're doing is
you're setting a uh intersectional
priority over who who gets to say what
who is allowed to level a critique so
even to the extent that you've deied the
hiring process and you've brought in
people who are unlikely to be as
meritorious in order to achieve these
high Dei numbers then you've made things
worse by creating a hierarchy of who can
critique whom because that wasn't so I
mean it's dangerous but it's not
dangerous to physical safety in a
college seminar but you put it in this
context and it's freaking lethal yeah
and this is exactly right and you the
fact is that college seminars don't
matter the stakes are zero right
that's that is both for better and worse
right like you're supposed to be able to
explore everything in a classroom where
actually the real world real world
consequences don't exist if however you
convince yourself if you create a system
in which you convince yourself and you
convince everyone in these seminars that
this is the highest Stakes possible and
that if they feel a little bit
uncomfortable or they feel like they're
about to cry or they feel anxious or
something then that really really really
matters and that this needs to be paid
attention to right away they go out into
the real world where there's actual
gravity and like there's actually
forces that matter and people fly places
and drive places and take Bridges and
are in buildings that were built that
were designed and built by people who
had their feelings hurt in a college
class once and they think that's what
matters of course the bridges are going
to start falling down and the buildings
and the planes are going to start
falling out of the sky and the door
plugs are going to be invited to
leave so this goes to another um piece
of toolkit that we have deployed the um
needs a better name but the theory of
close calls yeah right the idea is you
can infer something about dangers that
you can't afford to face even once by
the close calls that suggest you're
doing something wrong that keeps putting
you in danger right a door plug flying
out of a an airplane in flight is a
close call that is now calling our
attention to the process that allowed
that to happen yeah
and the fact is airplanes are
essentially the safest thing going and
there's basically an Institutional
memory about how to create them and
because they stay in service for a very
long time and because presumably uh you
know mechanics and engineers and safety
inspectors have long careers the Dei
madness has not yet created a wave of uh
airplane crashes however it will this is
the this is the first close call we spot
maybe in which this kind of stupid logic
is resulting in uh a compromise in the
structure of actual physical planes and
frankly you know 10 and some odd planes
have now been taken out of service which
creates more stresses on the system it's
going to mean airlines are reluctant to
take other planes out of service that
might need something they're going to be
pressured to keep them in service
because they don't have enough seats
flying from here to there so the
cascading effects for this are serious
we're still early in the process of Dei
eroding the thing that made air travel
safe we've still got a lot of stuff that
works out there and stuff that works
tends to work for a long time and so I
mean this is
it's it's the same thing that is true
actually about you know back 10 10 20
years ago as people started to talk
about well we need you know we we need
greater
representation in Academia of like what
the American populace looks
like I don't know that we need that but
say that it is a goal say that that is a
value that we hold and that we that we
need it's going to take a while uh
because it's quite one thing to say the
student we we would like the student
body to look like
uh the population of the US that should
be able to happen relatively quickly but
you want hire admin at colleges and
universities to be representative at the
same like like the student body is you
realize that 40 years ago there weren't
many people of color doing the work that
would have given them the experience and
the accolades so that they could be in a
position of of such higher power now
and therefore it's going to take a while
this is this is the like flip side of
that our things that are engineered and
built are not going to start falling
apart right away as soon as you
implement Dei practices because most
things continue to work because the
designs that were working that were
designed by people who were hired for
their Merit and not for their sexual
orientation uh continue to work but time
is ticking like with every passing day
those those systems that have been
working are closer to not working
because things fail they age they get
they they become obsolescent and new
designs are coming down the pike and any
of these new designs that have some Dei
hire on the team who was actually hired
because of their skin color and not
because of their Merit has a greater
chance of you know and was sitting in
these college seminars where if they
started to feel uncomfortable they got
to stop the conversation and talk about
their discomfort means that those
designs and therefore those builds are
much more likely to be flawed and
perhaps fatally so and in fact when we
have predicted this we've always said
this that there's going to be a delay
between the compromising of Merit and
the collapsing of these structures and
you know just think about it you know if
you decided that um furries had been
underrepresented in uh bridge design and
you started hiring you know only you
know I think they been actually I'm
almost certain of it
but I'm glad for it I'll say it that the
time has come and we're going to hire
only furries in the design and
inspection of bridges you're not going
to see Bridges collapsing suddenly right
you're going see it was safe guys I mean
it's the same it's the same
misunderstanding of safety y actually um
as as what happened with the roll out of
the
vaccines um so I did I don't think it
was the first time but I did find one of
the previous times that we have we we
have specifically made the prediction
that
you bring Dei into a corporation as one
of its important principles and you will
begin to see things fail um we talked
about it um about a year ago actually in
January 28th of 2023 on episode 159
Monkey Business at fizer when we
discussed that remember that project
Veritas video uh in which the founder
whose name I've forgotten who was then
drummed out for crazy
reasons Keef uh yeah um uh pretends to
be on a on a date with a fiser employee
uh and the fiser employee just dishes
dirt um and then at the point that it's
revealed that he that he's not talking
to um a possible date he's actually
talking to someone from prject Veritas
first he responds well I was lying about
all of it and then um and then he plays
the race card he's like I'm a black man
I'm being harmed here and I don't you I
don't remember exactly what he does but
it's it's ridiculous and a year ago
episode 159 we specifically talked about
that and predicted that once again that
moving Dei initiatives into uh places of
influence in corporations are going to
cause those corporations to end up doing
damage as they begin to fail here we go
Boeing yep and you know we've seen it in
government too you know Rachel LaVine is
uh not the person you want
managing uh Public Health no he is not
Sam Brinton was it was uh not the guy
you wanted managing managing nuclear
waste um but he stole some fabulous
dresses I would imagine he did but
anyway yeah enough of this right let's
put it this way you got you've got
essential systems compromising them on a
transparently insane compromising of
Merit uh is not something a rational
civilization would do uh we have not
been a rational civilization we've
started doing that it's time we stopped
yeah we need to stop we need to stop I
mean this this is
how many wake up calls do we need before
enough people wake up I don't know um
but I I wonder actually um all those
people on that plane out of Portland it
was a plane out of Portland but there
are a lot of people who don't want to
think on you know on that plane I should
finish that sentence but like a lot of
people on that plate who don't want to
think that um Dei initiative initiatives
could have any negative consequences at
all you know this is out of the city
that we called home and we know just how
ingrained Dei style thinking is
there
maybe maybe the mainstream media you
know push back against James
Lindsay's relatively straightforward
Research into what Boeing just puts into
its documents and Elon musk's retweeting
it and but the mainstream media is
already already already going like no it
had nothing to do with it they couldn't
possibly have had anything to do with it
so maybe no one on that plane even runs
into the possibility but I would hope
that something could be learned from
being on a plane where a door plug blows
out and you know some number of phones
get whipped out of the plane and you
know it's got to have been hopefully the
most terrifying several moments of all
of those people's lives right and they
got lucky because at low so lucky
um well some of them begin to wonder how
could this be allowed to happen and well
then they begin to talk to some of their
friends and their family and and it it
begins to spread how is it that we are
beginning to see fail where for a very
very long time we didn't see failures I
think for the moment at least we should
rename it diversity equity and explosive
decompression
right um I think so yeah yep yes the
unexpected departure of the door
plug left an opening you know plane yes
yeah um all right all right I think we
are I think we are all right um all
right so if you've been if you've been
been at the watch party at locals very
cool if you have not considered joining
us there we um we're doing our q&as
there now we won't be doing that today
but uh we do our q&as is there uh
including our what we've been doing our
monthly private Q&A um every on the last
Sunday of every month plus uh after a
live stream on the second second live
stream of every month and we also have
amas there we have our Discord server uh
lots of great stuff over at locals and
um we are uh we encourage please to not
just subscribe join us become a member
at locals but also subscribe to our
Rumble Channel it actually truly helps
us uh we're trying to grow our numbers
there and it it is growing whereas uh at
the moment that we got demonetized on
YouTube in the summer of 2021 and have
never since been remonetized the numbers
also stopped growing even though we have
many other indications that suggest that
our audience is growing but the numbers
are being juked at at YouTube and so
please come over to rumble um and and
subscribe cribe there it doesn't that
doesn't cost you anything um but it does
it does actually help us
tremendously um check out uh my weekly
writings at Natural Selections that's
natural selections. substack
docomo to the store darkhour store.org
where you can get lots of cool stuff
including our newest cut that out
shirt it's a good shirt it's a good
shirt um our younger son has been
wearing it around and uh garnering
supportive comments I am imagining I
don't know but I imagining as he walks
through the world that people are
cutting that out around him because
is that all it takes like a knife
through butter yeah exactly okay um what
else there's there's various oh um check
out our Wonder momentus Maui newie
Venison and frees spoke we got links to
those uh those sponsors and of course
everything else we talked about in the
show notes and just a reminder that we
are supported by you our audience we are
grateful to you and we are are helped
and gratified when you subscribe to our
Rumble Channel when you share uh things
that you see of that we are doing that
you appreciate when you join us on
locals when you subscribe um to either
full episodes or Clips uh on Rumble if
you must on YouTube um and anything else
to say before we sign off I don't think
so all right so we'll be back in a in a
week and a half uh not this Wednesday
but the following Wednesday until we see
you next time be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well
[Music]
everyone